So let's talk about managing chores.
Now what are chores? É Now, you may - given that you've - um
you've seen Pivotal Tracker and you're a
bit familiar with Agile development É
you've got some idea about about chores É
um - the important thing really is to distinguish chores from user stories
they're things that É
uh-
need to be done but they don't provide any direct obvious value to the customer.
So typically that's
umÉ you know - essential
jobs establishing frameworks or putting support in
that - you know - ultimately will support
É other - other stories
they're kind of just stuff that kind of has to be done
... though ultimately you know one wants as many chores as possible to be -
to be automated -
but that's the kind of ongoing thing of identifying you know where to put the
effort in about what to -
what to automate.
I mean É
you know, of course -
with the term chores
makes it sound like they might be
basic or menial jobs but actually they can be
very complex and - you know - require as
much skill and expertise as implementing
you know - a complex É complex feature so
you know - you will be at least partially
familiar with Pivotal Tracker as a
as a result of having done the
169 Engineering Software-as-a-Service course É
we'll be talking more about - you know -
the bigger picture with Pivotal Tracker
next week but É let's have a quick look
É at some of the É um É autumn projects here from Agile Ventures
these are all open and public
and you can go to them and see
you know - a real - a real project working there
but so we can see how for example here in the current thing we've got
um É you know -
there was a chore there to fix some broken domain name stuff
there was a domain name issue
uh-
that - that was previously working - it broke.
I mean it's - you know - arguably the customer
must have the É their - their site working in the
right location but - you know -
see, you could - sort of - all these things É - sort of
as long as you're a team is using a
consistent É metric for establishing that
this is what's going to be a chore and what's going to be a bug
we could have called that a bug rather than a chore
but often - if we have a look at some of the other bits & pieces -
- and now will that not go away?
go on É
uh- if we go back here
we can see that, for example,
adding code climate integration
into into the system - you know - in order
to check, because of code metrics,
automatically against pull requests É
that's something that the - you know -
the customer is not going to ask for - but it's going to be kinda
useful for the development team
and we'd like to have É going on É
So that's - that's a good example of a - of a chore.
The interesting thing is the impact of chores É
É they kind of have a
negative effect on the business -
business value output
and they're reducing velocity É they're not usually assigned points -
they're things that have got to be
done. You might be tempted,
and people often are, to say
"Well you know this is going to take - you know - what?
One or two points?" to sort of É you want to estimate
how long they're going to take - but
Pivotal and others strongly recommend against doing that.
It's sort of - they just sort of - it's part of the cost of -
of being in business É and so -
you know -
the time that it takes to get those chores done -
along with the the features is kind of É
ends up - you know - helping with the É the uh É
velocity calculation É but
more on that when we come to it next next week.
Uh, yeah - they can also represent
you know - code debt, sort of refactoring needs to be done,
you know - points of dependency on other teams.
You don't necessarily know in advance what your chores are going to be -
they sort of you know just come up each week
and É uh - sort keeping it É
it's very important to keep a track of
all these things that need to be done as well as the things
that uh É you know -
the user stories that have real business value
and É
get - to a certain extent
the automatic velocity of calculation can -
can free you up from having to worry about -
about you know exactly how much É
they - they take up in terms of resources, time spent É
um, so - they can you know they can be high priority
um - it can be that a critical chore
you know, with a bit of infrastructure
has to be done in order
to support some of the some of the story
maybe multiple stories - multiple teams even É
and so,
you know - coordinating, getting these done, is - is important É
umÉ and it's É you know - that's where
in systems like Tracker
where you can reorder things
and put things into one sprint or another
um É is - is very useful É but the key thing here
really, for - you know -
individuals, centralized teams, distributed teams,
is, you know - remembering these things need to be done
É kind of, distinguishing, in your mind
from the -
the high-level user stories that then are
really driving business value and,
you know - choosing out those things that need to be chores
but that's something - again, I think - you know - continually using
systems like Pivotal where all of the work you're doing
is being broken into
uh É you know - high-level user stories,
chores, bugs É and so forth
is definitely the way to go.
We don't make as much use, I think, as we should do
of releases É it's partly, you know - it's just,
these open source projects for non-profit organizations
are slightly slower -
slower paced É but yes -
understanding chores É uh - very important!